>> Greg: HATERS SEE HIS RACE.
PRETAKEN ELON WAS A TERRIBLE
FELLOW BECAUSE HE DIDN'T FREE
NELSON MANDELA.
SO ELON MUSK OUTBID ME AND
BOUGHT TWITTER.
HE'S NOW LABELLED A RACIST.
GET IT?
HERE'S HEADLINES.
CNN SAYS ELON MUSK'S POSSIBLE
TAKEOVER OF TWITTER IS
UNSETTLING FOR MANY BLACK USERS.
ROLLING STONE, ELON MUSK PREVIEW
WHAT HE DOES WITH TWITTER.
L.A. TIMES, WITH MUSK IN CHARGE,
IT'S THE BEGINNING OF THE END
FOR BLACK TWITSER.
THERE'S THIS ONE FROM
HIGHLIGHTS.
DUFAS LOVES ELON.
GALANT, NOT SO MUCH.
I FIGURED SOMEBODY WOULD GET
THAT.
COME ON.
WHO DIDN'T READ HIGHLIGHTS?
SHUTS UP, KAT.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" THAT
TWEETED ELON MUSK GREW UP IN
ELITE WHITE COMMUNITIES IN SOUTH
AFRICA.
IF YOU READ THE ARTICLE, YOU
FOUND OUT THAT HE HAD BLACK
FRIENDS AND WAS BULLIED FOR
STANDING UP TO RACIST CHILDREN.
HE FLED FROM SOUTH AFRICA WHEN
HE WAS 17.
YES, ELON LEFT HIS ALL WHITE
COMMUNITY.
HIS MOTHER STEPPED IN TWEETING.
IN SOUTH AFRICA, IF YOU PUBLICLY
OPPOSED APARTHEID, YOU WENT TO
JAIL.
IN RUSSIA, IF YOU OPPOSE THE
WAR, YOU'RE GOING TO JAIL.
WAY TO GO, MOM.
ELON BETTER GET HER SOMETHING
NICE FOR MOTHER'S DAY.
WHY NOT BUY HER "THE NEW YORK
TIMES"?
I DON'T THINK THEY CAN CANCEL
THIS GUY.
HE'S TOO RICH, KENNEDY.
HE'S NOT LIKE A NORMAL PERSON.
IF THEY COME AFTER THEM, HE WILL
BUY THEM.
>> WHEN YOU MAKE ROCKETS AND
YOU'RE SENDING HUMANS TO MARS,
YOU HAVE PROVEN THAT YOU HAVE
F.U. MONEY AND YOU DON'T CARE.
YOU WILL BUILD SOMETHING OR YOU
WILL BUY SOMETHING COOLER EVEN
IF IT'S JUST TO DISTRACT
YOURSELF OR SOOTHE YOUR OWN
FEELINGS.
DID WE LEARN NOTHING FROM BRETT
KAVANAUGH?
HIS MOM IS RIGHT.
YOU CANNOT BLAME HIM FOR WHOM HE
WAS BORN TO OR WHERE HE WAS
BORN.
THE SECOND YOU HAVE THE CHOICE
TO LEAVE, THAT'S WHEN YOU'RE AN
ADULT.
HE MADE THAT CHOICE.
HE LEFT.
HE DEPARTMENT GO BACK, THIS IS
AN ENTIRELY MANUFACTURED STORE
REPRESENTATIVE BY PEOPLE THAT
HAVE NO PERSONAL EXPERIENCE IN
SOUTH AFRICA AND REALLY DON'T
UNDERSTAND HIS LIFE OR WHERE
HE'S FROM.
IT'S AN IMPOSITION TRYING TO
CREATE A PERCEPTION LIKE DEFUND
THE POLICE.
IT'S OVERLY SIMPLISTIC AND
ULTIMATELY HARMFUL.
>> Greg: WE TALKED ABOUT THIS
YESTERDAY, KAT.
COMPLAINING THAT MUSK WILL MAKE
TWITTER WORSE IS LIKE SAYING AN
AUTOPSY MUST HURT THE CORPSE.
>> YEAH.
>> Greg: HOW CAN YOU MAKE
TWITTER WORSE?
TWITTER MAKES ME -- I -- IT'S
LIKE I'M A HYPOCRITE.
I GO --
>> YOU ARE A HYPOCRITE.
YOU TELL ME ALL THE TIME, YOU'RE
LIKE DON'T READ YOUR MENTIONS
BECAUSE YOU DON'T NEED TO SEE
THAT.
THEN I SEE YOU LATE QUOTE
TWEETING EVERYONE.
>> YOU GIVE AWAY ALL OF YOUR
MATERIAL.
I WOULDN'T HAVE ANYTHING TO
WRITE IN MY BOOK IF I'M GIVING
IT AWAY EVERY DAY.
>> TWITTER IS A PLACE YOU DON'T
GET PAID FOR ANYTHING YOU SAY
BUT YOU CAN GET FIRED FOR IT.
>> I DON'T GET ON FACEBOOK.
I'M NOT INTERESTED FOR WHAT YOU
HAVE FOR LUNCH.
>> IT'S BAD.
AGAIN, IT'S NOT THAT MANY PEOPLE
ARE ON IT.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE
POPULATION IS NOT ON TWITTER.
SO IF HE SOMEHOW MADE IT WORSE,
WHICH I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU
WOULD, IT WOULDN'T AFFECT MOST
PEOPLE.
THEY'RE LIKE DEMOCRACY ITSELF IS
GOING TO CRUMBLE.
YOU LISTEN TO YOURSELF?
CALM DOWN.
>> I HOPE HE BUYS THE BIG NEW
MARILYN MONROE PAINTING THAT
WILL BREAK THE RECORDS.
I HOPE HE GETS THAT.
THAT WILL MAKE PEOPLE SO NUTS.
>> Greg: IF I HAD THAT KIND OF
MONEY, I WOULD BUY THINGS THAT
UPSET PEOPLE.
I WOULD BUY THE YANKEE AND DRIVE
THEM IN TO THE GROUND.
>> I DON'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
SPORTS EITHER.
I WAS THE NIKE AD THIS YEAR.
NO ONE HAS EVER THROWN ME A BALL
IN MY LIFE.
NOT ONCE.
>> WELL -- ARE YOU SURE?
>> EVEN MY DAD GAVE UP.
>> YEAH, MY DAD STOPPED GOING TO
THE GAMES.
IT WAS SAD, DAGEN.
>> I LIKE "THE NEW YORK TIMES."
I KNOW.
THAT'S A TERRIBLE THING TO SAY
HERE.
THEY JUST GAVE MY BOOK A GREAT
REVIEW.
BUT I UNDERSTAND THE RAGE.
I GET WHY PEOPLE ARE SO
BUSINESSED OFF.
I HAVE A BLACK FRIEND IN
BALTIMORE.
SHE SAID A GUY WANTED HER BANK
ROUTING NUMBER.
HE SAID WHY.
HE SENT HER $50.
SHE SAID WHAT IS THIS FOR.
HE SAID YOU KNOW, SLAVERY.
SHE WAS SO OUTRAGED.
HE SAID YOU KNOW.
I UNDERSTAND.
THE RAGE.
THAT'S WHY JET MAGAZINE SHOULD
COME OUT NOW AS A HIPSTER BLACK
MAGAZINE THAT MAKES FUN OF
CLUELESS WHITE REACTIONS TO
BLACK LIVES MATTER.
THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
I LOVE JET.
REMEMBER THAT?
>> Greg: IT WAS --
>> IT WAS A DOWN SCALE BUT THEY
SPECIALIZED IN PUBLISHING ARETHA
FRANKLIN'S OUTFITS.
>> IT WAS BIG.
IT WAS AT THE FRONT OF THE
STORE.
IT WAS STRANGE IN THOSE DAYS.
>> BUT SOLD HUGE AMOUNTS.
>> WE HAD DIFFERENT MAGAZINES AT
OUR LIQUOR STORE.
IT WAS LIKE THUGS WITH THREE Gs.
>> Greg: I MISS THE OLD MAGAZINE
RACK.
>> I KNOW.
I HAVE ONE IN MY HOUSE.
LOOKS LIKE A DENTIST OFFICE.
BUT NOW I GO ON AIRPLANES, I
USED TO HAVE LIKE $100 OF
MAGAZINES.
YOU HAND THEM ONE, IT'S LIKE I
HAND THEM A TERD.
>> Greg: WE'LL TALK ABOUT THAT
IN THE NEXT BLOCK.
HE'S NOT DONE ANYTHING YET.
PEOPLE ARE FREAKING OUT.
WHAT IF NOTHING CHANGES?
IF THIS IS ALL FOR NOTHING.
>> IT'S -- WELL, IT'S NOT ALL
FOR NOTHING.
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" CLEARLY RAN
THAT PHOTO TO TROLL HIM TO SHOW
HIS -- WELL, WHEN HE HAD REAL
HAIR.
WHEN IT WASN'T LIKE A SYSTEM.
>> Greg: YES.
>> NUMBER 1.
NUMBER 2, WHERE IN THE HELL HAVE
THEY BEEN THE LAST 20 YEARS?
HE'S BUILT A GIANT ROBOT ARMY OF
AUTOMOBILES THAT ARE REMOTE
CONTROLLED.
THERE'S LIKE TWO MILLION ROBOTS
OUT THERE AND HE'S [BLEEP] IN TO
SPACE.
WE DON'T KNOW IF IT'S PEACEFUL.
WHAT IS HE PUTTING UP THERE?
SATELLITES TO CONTROL HIS VAST
VEHICLE ARMY AND OUR MINDS?
>> Greg: THIS IS WHY'S BEEN SO
COMPLIMENTARY.
I'M THE BENEDICT ARNOLD HERE.
WHEN HE BECOMES THE EVIL DEMON,
HE WILL REMEMBER ME AND KILL ALL
OF YOU PEOPLE.
I'M GOING TO BE LIKE HIS LITTLE
JESTER.
I'LL SIT ON HIS LAP.
KILL THEM, ELON.
KILL THEM.
[APPLAUSE]